à
c'est une expérience tout simplement
belle aventure on a fait la connaissance
de beaucoup de personnes on ne sait pas
ce qu'il ya de tout horizon et même nos
voisins les plus proches
on connaissait pas forcément
ils se sont approprié le spectacle
exactement comme je voulais c'est à dire
que c'était là c'est leur spectacle
quand j'ai franchi la porte j'ai pleuré
parce que c'est le cheval était un peu
gros pour moi un peu grand et j'étais
ému le record 7 l'émotion je l'étais lui
par la fierté que j'avais de faire
quelque chose ici
après un artiste sait exactement quand
on lui dit c'est impossible qui
commencent à travailler
voilà donc j'ai commencé à travailler
tout de suite ça fait un an
m
il est scénographe il est aussi peintre
et diplômé d'architecturé
mais si cet artiste complet accepte le
projet fou que lui propose le directeur
de la saline c'est d'abord pour y
inclure des hommes et des femmes et fait
déjà semblerait des grands pas vous
allez à la fête beaucoup plus physique
allez on essaye tout faire en même temps
là les fêtes le sam a demandé six mois
de travail pour flâner dans leurs
campagnes aller voir les gens parce que
je suis allé voir les gens faire des
réunions invité les gens dans les bars
partout dans les écoles et j'expliquais
ce que je voulais faire
jordi si le si le pari vous plaît ils
ont su je suis allé le premier à la
première réunion d'information et on en
parle ans après à table à l'occasion
pourquoi pas martin a suivi mon épouse
et puis louis à la suite donc
finalement on se retrouve les quatre
dans l' aventure on a adhéré tout de
suite au projet donc on est allé à la
première réunion de dominique et puis
voilà voilà
ça a bien fonctionné que dominique y met
les gens à l'aise et on était partant
tout de suite quoi c'est normal que je
participe en tant que voisin est bien
cuit et demande à la saline plus ça
m'intéresse eh ben j'ai été contacté par
mail par sa ligne en si je voulais
participer à cette aventure
donc j'ai dit ok moi cette année j'avais
à paris quand même à face à vous moi
j'arrive de discuter via quand je dis
moi je veux faire ça c'était l'an
dernier au mois d'août
l'hormadi mais vous êtes arcas temps
vous n'êtes pas de pot atf d'accent moi
j'ai pas accès alors moi je peux dire
que j'ai pas d'accès toi t'as pas de pot
puis deux semblent puis 300 au fil des
mois la troupe est de plus en plus
fournie avec un petit groupe de fidèles
qui en plus des répétitions se
retrouvent pour bricoler ou coudre 55 4
911 a fait la quinzaine de copains
là c'est l'atelier de couture du
spectacle luxe à l'ina donc on a une
dizaine de costumes 18e à faire les pour
john et la corde à claudine la fin quand
sûr il nous en reste sans savoir que
qu'on est peut-être une erreur qu'on
fait tout ça qu on fait nos costumes
avec la récupération
non donc ça c'est du billard du tissu de
récup et des vieilles dentelles
ça c'est un petit plus de commandes du
tissu pour la france et le petit je suis
content france est derrière s'est passé
pendant ces événements et on a créé mon
tout ça on customise on se régale et
chacun amène sa petite touche de de
personnel et ont créé comme des
vocations
d'abord dos et le travail donc la saline
qui enfin palais mais une usine est en
activité
l'important c'est que votre torche vous
allez vous à main va faire en rond dans
la nuit qui va simuler les engrenages de
lusine qui achemine le stelle à l' usine
qui va être transformé par les images en
musique à athènes
abandonnez vous allez entendre une
sonnerie à la sonnerie pour une sonnerie
c'est une belle sonnerie vous faites
demi tour et au fait deux pas en avant
à ce moment là les les projecteurs qui
sont derrière vous vous projetez en
ombres chinoises sur le mur de la saline
où on verra aussi des images projetées
la saline vie elle s'anime pour raconter
sa longue histoire avec des images et
des animations née de la palette de cet
homme et de son équipe
évidemment on prépare toutes nos images
sur écran d'ordinateur mais ensuite on
transpose sur des volumes donc chaque
image doit être construite par rapport à
ces volumes l'échelle des lieux oblige
aussi à tous sur dimensionner le moment
c'est sur le bâtiment c suis convaincu
c'est pas du tout comparable mais non on
dit toujours habillé un bâtiment par
l'image
habillée par la lumière on a un peu dans
des termes de couture finalement est
passée un peu comme quelqu'un qui aurait
conçu un très beau costume et tant qu'il
n'a pas vu défiler sur le podium
il a encore des doutes mais
il attend sur noir que
je voulais ce qui est vraiment plus des
impressions des émotions autour de cette
sale in qu'une histoire voilà très
écrite très historiciser donc j'ai
voyagé plus fait plutôt partie sur ses
tableaux là moi j'ai fait un synopsis en
quelque sorte et puis après je les
livrer aux artistes je veux pas me
substituer à ceux qui font le travail
mais c'est vrai que j'ai tenu à cadrer
un peu le fil rouge de cette histoire de
la saline annexe 1 accentuant sur les
moments importants pour le tableau de la
destruction le rappelle nous quand même
fier directeur l'histoire de toutes ces
destructions
alors ce tableau sur la destruction on
l'a fait parce qu'il ya eu une période
noire de la saline c'est en 1927
quand les salines de l'est ce
propriétaire du bâtiment ont fait
exploser les colonnes de la maison du
directeur
donc là ils l'ont fait pour des raisons
de pure proprement mercantile il voulait
pas être classés de ça les grandes berne
leur servait de dépôt et donc ils sont
dissuadés classions pourra plus faire
venir les camions etc
esaü laisser totalement inverse et la
propriété a été transférée au
département du doubs qui en est toujours
le propriétaire
professionnels du spectacle et bénévoles
occupe désormais toute la saline chacun
se prépare à vivre ensemble la même
aventure artistes on peut refaire un
tour pour l'année en train de dévorer
les chevaux parce qu'il faut que le
cheval aussi s'entraîne à tous les
bruits et là aujourd'hui dieu sait si à
tous les bruits faits s'il ya tous les
machines au a pris par tant de la cia
deux ânes devant comme il ya maintenant
le cheval il suit l'année il y est donc
c'est l'élément moteur s'est elle j'ai
voulu la mettre en valeur
elle plus que moi parce qu'en fin de
compte on peut en voir et puis je tiens
particulièrement c'est pour faire
reconnaître un peu ce cet animal qui est
toujours méprisé tenu le machin qui en
elle commence à prendre ses marques vont
se déboîtant d'adaptation en plus cet
après midi il fait chaud il ya musique
s'est écrite baleine donc huguette et
trois traducteurs et des baleines dans
la région et il ya plein de travaux de
tracteurs mais dans la salle et avec sa
barbe de sens à vannes ce que ça va être
encore plus fort le soir du spectacle
donc ça on n'a pas essayé un peu pas
trop savoir mais apparemment on
couperait un peu les haut parleurs qui
sont de ce côté là pour pas qu'elle soit
pas directement et faire
c'est pas juste un spectacle de
projection qu'on va faire justement
assez la falloir s'adapter aux
contraintes des figurants des animaux
n'est donc ça c'est super intéressant ça
mène vraiment une dimension humaine et
d'improvisation non ça nous intéresse
alors je fais le cheval allait lui
dominique vétérans scène scénariste
c'est nous motiver aussi rester simple
et nous faire nous donner envie de
participer de façon conviviale aussi à
la tête d'un spectacle on se contente du
tout non non c'est vraiment venez comme
vous êtes faites ce que vous voulez
aussi chacun apporte sa petite touche et
c'est ça qui est intéressant
noah le metteur en scène je suis très
confiant du spectacle qui va être une
réussite
j'en suis sûr que ça voilà et vous
n'allez pas être ridicule parce que moi
c'est ça que je sais ça que je cherche
et c'est votre spectacle et puis six
mois qu'on travaille avait aucune
inquiétude vous concernant
1 la sab le mans dominique dessine sa
caravane du sel en enchaînant les
répétitions
soir après soir petits groupes après
petit groupe parce qu'elle n'y est pas
j'ai demandé à alain geiger sont de
mettre une vraie sonnerie pour la
deuxième fois c'est en fait la trompette
30 emplois ah oui parce que dans la
nouvelle bande son comme aura je pense
demain ou après demain il ya une vraie
sonnerie comme la première palacio au
double quand même parce que sinon on
partira pas
là vous êtes des guerriers c'est de
respecter les autres
c'est très bien ne levait pas le bâton
trop vous allez avoir un guest tu vas
avoir mal au roi là vous êtes les
gardiens du temps pour aller allumer la
lux salines à la lumière n'a pas besoin
de répéter on n'a même pas eu deux
autres pour encore s'il faudra qu'une
phase de perdre des chefs à bagnolet des
vallées ce lundi je découvre des roms ou
csv à huy te fais des bâtons voix ah oui
quel noël 4,9
voilà une journée bien chargée mais très
excitant parce que même à 20 heures elle
à 21h ils ont encore l'énergie pour pour
pour rajouter des petites choses là
c'est des petites répète de petits
groupes
donc on rentre un peu dans les détails
et en poche il un peu la partie
technique elle aussi en est à la phase
finale peut dire à tous de venir une
petite seconde
s'il te plaît il est au milieu des
flanades là devant la maison du
directeur il s'agit de régler
l'éclairage grandeur nature sur les
façades du monument
la bande vidéo elle est prête de toute
façon c'est là c'est vraiment calé les
appareils sur le monument est calée nos
masques par rapport aux monuments
puisque c'est le mapping
donc on a pris une photo des bâtiments
et d'après cette photo on a tiré un
calque et sur ce calque on a dessiné le
spectacle donc on part d'une image qui
est la reproduction exacte du bâtiment
et on va amener des modifications et du
coup ça donne une animation qui est très
surprenante parce qu'on a l'impression
que le bâtiment lui même vit bouge
essayez tout l'espace
alors moi il serait bien c'est qu'on
soit c'est un petit chèque par rapport
au déplacement des figurants et les par
rapport à tes top départ et que je
puisse leur portée sur la conduite parce
que j'ai alors je te pourrait donner une
d une conduite définitive de marche vers
midi d'accord on se prend un petit apéro
en fait un check check des places fortes
baisses en même temps que le spectacle
démarre on vous donnera une feuille de
route où il y aura tout le plan des
déplacements de tout le spectacle
abandonnez vous allez entendre pas
d'aller à la main il avoue sortie
d'impôts ça dure cinq fois à la bêtise
là
et là vous dansez puisqu'on est dans les
musiques d'après guerre dont glenn
miller voilà là vous dans ces deux par
deux et vous mettez le drapeau sous le
bras
je sais bien qu'on fait un peu plus de
femmes
ouais c'est bien car rené l'espace pour
l'espace gestion data pour faire oui
c'est bien là c'est bien
non
vous décidez ses désavantages
c'est très bien je vois que très simple
c'est super ça c'est fait pour faire des
publicités c'est des années 50
voilà c'est le chic rue félix et alsace
et nous savons c'est c'est c
et voilà et on va faire tout un
jeu scénographique avec ses cartons et
les images projetées qui vont nous
rappeler des années 50 et les publicités
jean mineur dont peillon le présent jeu
temps des fleurs sur l'avenir
alsa al jarreau là je ne lui aurais le
chien de balzac
un chant derbal temps normal on ne fait
pas mieux y avons joué vous allez voir
l'union on ne peut pas se louper c'est
un grand lyon qui la grandeur de la
saline
c'est le lion de belfort le lion de la
france comptait c'est le lion qui marche
comme un égyptien il ya ce moment là
vous prenez vos cartons fait guère
attention les cartons ne sont pas
terminées il a bien sûr ses cartons de
répétition mais vous aurez une phase qui
est plus flatteuse
à vous de choisir à belfast pour
présenter au public et vous partez comme
des égyptiens avec le carton comme ça en
file indienne
enfin martin saint dominique le stresse
un oui je sais ça ne vous laissez pas
prendre ça c'est normal vous allez avoir
le trac moi j'ai le trac j'ai 40 ans de
métier ça a été toute ma vie vous allez
vous allez voir que quand vous avez
démarré il ya plus personne qui sait ce
qu'il a à faire mais je mettrais devant
ce que j'appelle un aboyeur de meute qui
lui sont rares et il va partir et vous
le suivait tranquillement c'est pas trop
inquiète pas du tout pensé ou est-ce
qu'il pôle nord et le pôle sud parce que
j'étais souvent des cartes face à
l'écossé s'écoute sieda culte c'est bien
hawass est acquis c'est moi depuis des
semaines la saline royale grouille de
monde de bruit et de musique avec la
préparation de luxe à li na
elle est comme descendu d'un piédestal
fier harmonieuse mais accessible rendu à
son territoire et à ses habitants la
saline à ces deux visages d'un lieu de
travail et d'un lieu prestigieux c'est
un château usines et dans l'histoire il
ya eu la période usine avec des lois
sociales dans jours de travail en jours
de repos à au xviiie siècle c'est assez
utopique c'est des gens qui travaillent
sur place qui logent sur place il ya une
école sur place et les commerces sur
place ils ont les jardins sur place
c'est une utopie sociale et après c'est
redevenu un château et après ses revenus
une usine et puis là c'était un peu
devenu un lieu populaire est fermée au
public quand même voilà et c'est ce pari
là qui a acquis qu'on est en train de
2,2 de jouer c'est de redonner ce lieu
sa popularité et son cô té i grand
public ouvert ça changeait de direction
récemment les années précédentes c'est
trop sophistiqué beau pour les pour la
région pour mon avis là parce que elle
faisait des trucs sur la philosophie
même si cette personne non c'est pas le
nommer sa tête par la sous population
des plus populaires ont trouvé que voilà
les salines c'était les salines et au
milieu d'arqués ce temps mais qui avait
pas de lien voilà c'est vrai que et on
discute en même avec des personnes qui
sont artistes sur arc-et-senans où on ne
les a jamais sollicité pour quoi que ce
soit dans leur art je trouvais ça
dommage comme il avait eu parfois dans
le passé le sentiment que la saleen
était un monde
ben qui était clos pour eux ce qui est
étonnant c'est vraiment hors au milieu
du village du quartier sonore c'est le
trait d'union c'est la saline royale
donc c'est vrai je n'ai ressenti s'est
exprimé et cette idée de spectacle vient
de là c'était renouer avec avec la
population locale
on aurait pu effectivement commandé un
spectacle à l'extérieur et puis voilà ça
sent les gens sont revenus aussi mais je
voulais absolument qu'ils aient une
participation publique qui est des gens
qui s'investissent dedans et ça a
fonctionné et je crois qu'on en a renoué
avec le tissu associatif local
il aura fallu des mois de préparation
des dizaines de répétition et beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie pour qu'à 13 reprises
pendant l'été la saline se raconte et
s'illumine
soyez concentré c'est tout ce que je
demande ne parlez pas quand vous ne
jouez pas parce que c'est ça qui vous
regarde pas ce que vous déconcentrer
essayer de savoir ce que vous avez à
faire est de rester dans le jeu ci après
vous planter c'est pas grave ça n'arrête
pas le spectacle qu'ils arrêtent le
spectacle cfsi le top départ vous le
louper ça oui ça sert là on est dedans
et moi là je sais pas vous rattraper
c'est bon merci en place je veux un
un spectacle se moquer dur à dire plus
d'émotions donc je veux que les gens
participent à une vente et aventure
humaine vraiment et c'est assez fou
parce que c'est en train de me débordé
je suis au dessus du cheval et je suis
en équilibre sur un pied et je suis
d'une fragilité incroyable mais je sais
qu'en bas il me rattraperont parce que
c'est eux qui vont ils vont faire le
spectacle
l'imagination
obélie l'image
enlevez vos habits et vous enlevez vos
pantxo vous enlevez vos accessoires les
lampes
merci beaucoup et superbe casting
je suis très heureux pour vous les amis
mes amours mes francs mais franches mais
comme toi mais quand oise mais pendules
à l'heure que vous dire de plus que vous
ne savez déjà c'est que vous avez
investi ce spectacle de votre énergie
quand vous rentrez vous fait peur
tellement vous êtes fort paris c'était
de retrouver une communauté par là parce
que ça c'est mon métier et je sais que
pour faire ce pour faire se réunir les
gens à les faire vivre et celia et que
l'émotion mais c'est pas la faute moi je
préfère une vraie tristesse à une fausse
joie mais là c'était une vraie joie une
vraie joie des gens de se retrouver dans
un village qui avait la fierté de dire
notre salines
on l'a réinvestis et c'est nous qui
avons fait le spectacle
ça c'est quand même fabuleux alors qui
est là l'année prochaine et le droit
merci
m
et
l'essai